a twin attack at night with drones on
two major Saudi oil facilities one of
largest in the world this was an
extraordinary operation the scale the
method and the impact for the Yemeni
rebel army who carried it out it was so
successful that it has reportedly forced
Saudi Arabia to shut down half its oil
production the two plants were hit just
before 4:00 a.m. and they were burning
into the morning they are east of the
capital Riyadh hundreds of miles from
Yemen and yet it seems still an
achievable target for the Iranian backed
rebel group analysts have long said that
this plant is Saudi Arabia's Achilles
heel if it is shut down for an extended
period the implications will be global
[Music]
on a TV station owned by the Houthi
rebels a commander boasted of a precise
attack with ten drones
he claimed that help from people inside
Saudi Arabia had made this possible and
he said it was a measured response to
crimes and aggression from Saudi Arabia
and her allies inside Yemen for four and
a half years now a saudi-led coalition
with British weapons has been fighting
alongside the government in Yemen
against the Houthi rebel group whose
back as Iran make this a dangerous power
struggle the consequence is regional
instability and the world's worst
humanitarian crisis an intractable mess
with no clear Victor the Hootie's now
feel as though there is great
opportunity to bring this first of all
to the global awareness and they
certainly have chosen a major location
to do that the overnight attack follows
a pattern in June a Houthi cruise
missile struck an international airport
in March last year seven ballistic
missiles were fired some reaching the
Saudi capital Riyadh one person was
killed and in December 2017 Saudi air
defenses intercepted a Houthi missile
which had a royal palace in its sights
but the use of small drones here is a
development to achieve new technologies
low-grade attacks are disproportionately
effective and are becoming a global
threat
two weeks ago Israel released this
footage
which acclaim shows iranian-backed
fighters in syria trying to launch an
attack drone to hit Israel they claimed
Iran's elite hoods force was behind it
there is no proof that Iran was behind
last night's attack but the Kurds Force
Commander Qasem Soleimani praised the
Houthi tactics the Saudi government says
the fires are now under control but the
damage physically isn't clear and
economically it could be huge mark stone
Sky News